SAID AT THAT TIME?
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS STUFF UP.
TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT WE BEGIN IN FLORIDA
WHERE HURRICANE RECOVERY EFFORTS
ARE ONGOING.
EARLIER TODAY BIDEN MADE THAT
SPECIAL TRIP TO THE SUNSHINE
STATE WHERE HE WAS IN FACT
CAUGHT ON THAT HOT MIC SAYING
EXACTLY WHAT WE JUST TOLD YOU.
>> I WAS.
>> NO ONE WAS --
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> SUCH A TOUGH GUY, GOING TO
TAKE HIM BEHIND THE SCHOOL AND
BEAT HIM UP.
TOUGH GUY.
BUT HE FALLS OVER WITH THE WIND,
GOING ON AIR FORCE ONE.
NOBODY Fs WITH THE BIDEN EXCEPT
FOR VENEZUELA, SAUDI ARABIA,
EVERY OTHER OPEC NATION.
WE'LL EXPLAIN IN DETAIL.
RECENTLY, BIDEN GOT ON HIS
KNEES, HANDS AND KNEES BEGGING
AND PLEADING THE SAUDI'S CROWN
PRINCE TO PLEASE PRODUCE MORE
OIL.
HE'S BEEN BEGGING OPEC AS WELL.
THE SAME CROWN PRINCE IN THIS
CASE THAT BIDEN OPENLY REFER TO
AS A PARIAH, THAT HE ACCUSED OF
TORTURING AND MURDERING THE
JOURNALIST JAMAL KAVHOGGHI.
OPEC SAYS THEY WILL BE REDUCING
OIL PRODUCTION BY A WHOPPING 2
MILLION BARRELS A DAY THAT WILL
REDUCE SUPPLY AND INCREASE THE
PRICE OF THE A BARREL OF OIL.
THIS IS NOT ONLY DEEPLY
HUMILIATING FOR JOE BIDEN AND
THE U.S., MOST IMPORTANTLY, IT
IS PAINFUL TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
NOW, GAS BUDDIES, PATRICK IS
PREDICTING OPEC'S DECISION TODAY
WILL DRIVE PASSES UP TO 15 TO
30CENTS PER GLAND.
LOOK AT THIS, $5 IN RENO.
$6.42 IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S AVERAGE.
$5.47 IN OREGON.
$4.51 IN ARIZONA.
AND HERE WE GO AGAIN.
THIS YEAR ALONE, AMERICAN
FAMILIES, THEY ARE SHELLING OUT
A WHOPPING $7,200 TO COVER COST
ASSOCIATED ALL DUE TO BIDEN HE
IS INFLATION, RECOGNIZELESS
SPENDING -- WRECKLESS SPENDING.
$7,200 PER HOUSEHOLD.
THIS IS BEYOND DEVASTATING TO
THE POOR, THE MIDDLE CLASS AND,
OF COURSE, IT'S CLOBBERING THOSE
PEOPLE ON FIXED INTUM
COMES.
BUT REMEMBER, NOTHING IS EVER
BIDEN'S FAULT.
HE GETS CREDIT WHEN GRAMS GO
DOWN -- GAS PRICES GO DOWN, BUT
HE DOESN'T TAKE THE BLAME WHEN
THEY GO BACK UP.
LAST WEEK THEY WERE LASHING OUT
BLAMING OIL COMPANIES, NOW
THEY'RE SAYING THAT OPEC IS
COLLUDING WITH MOTHER RUSSIA.
>> LOOK, IT'S CLEAR THAT OPEC IS
ALIGNING WITH RUSSIA WITH
TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT.
AND I'LL LEAVE IT AS THAT, AS I
JUST LAID OUT.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A TIME WHERE
WE ARE, YOU KNOW, THE GLOBAL
MARKET -- THE GLOBAL ECONOMY IS
RESPONDING TO PUTIN'S WAR.
>> THAT'S THE THING ABOUT
EXPORTING YOUR ENERGY NEEDS.
YOU CANNOT CONTROL WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES DO.
JOE BIDEN CAUSED ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS WHEN HE ABANDONED THE
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE POLICIES
THAT HE GOT FROM DONALD TRUMP SO
NOW WHAT'S BIDEN'S RESPONSE?
GET THIS.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE THIS.
HE NOW PLANS TO BEG ANOTHER
ANTI-AMERICAN COUNTRY, A
DICTATOR, THUG TO GET MORE OIL
AND HAS A NEW PROPOSALS TO LIFT
SANCTIONS ON VENEZUELA.
IF THERE'S A CHANCE, IT CAN HELP
SALVAGE A FEW SEATS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE MID TERMS.
THIS IS INSANITY BUT IT GETS
WORSE.
TODAY THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCED
ANOTHER 10 MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL WILL BE RELEASED FROM THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE
DESPITE PROMISING TO DO THE
EXACT OPPOSITE ONLY YESTERDAY.
WATCH.
>> THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
RESERVE, THE RUNOFF RELEASE THAT
1 MILLION BARRELS A DAY ENDS AT
THE END OF THIS MONTH.
IS THERE ANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
RELEASING MORE OIL FROM THE
STRATEGIC OIL RESERVE?
HOW IS THE PRESIDENT GOING TO
KEEP THE SUPPLY UP?
>> WE'RE NOT CONSIDERING NEW
RELEASES, RELEASES FROM THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE
BEYOND THE 180 MILLION, WHICH IS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, THAT THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED MONTHS AGO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING MORE TO
SHARE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CONSIDERING NEW RELEASES.
>> DON'T FORGOT.
THE PETROLEUM RESERVE, THAT IS
INTENDED FOR NATIONAL
EMERGENCIES.
LOOK AT HOW MUCH HE IS DEPLETED,
THOSE RESERVES.
IT'S FOR AN EMERGENCY.
BIDEN HAS ALMOST COMPLETELY
DRAINED THE SUPPLY.
WE ARE NOW AT A 40 YEAR LOW.
IT IS NOT A NATIONAL EMERGENCY,
JOE, THAT DEMOCRATS ARE LIKELY
TO LOSE AN ELECTION SO YOU
ARTIFICIALLY RAISE THE WORLD
SUPPLY OF OIL IN A LEAD UP TO AN
ELECTION TO LOW THE PRICE TO
CREATE A FALSE PERCEPTION THAT
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING GOOD.
YOU'RE NOW CREATING A NATIONAL
SECURITY VULNERABILITY BECAUSE
YOU'RE DRAINING THE VERY
RESERVES BEFORE AN ELECTION TO
REDUCE AND LOWER PRICES.
IT'S ONLY A BAND-AID.
I TOLD YOU IT WAS ONLY A
BAND-AID.
AND YOU WILL ONLY DO IT TO
ELECTION DAY AND THEN OF COURSE
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY THE
PIPER.
AND YET GRAMS CONTINUE -- GAS
PRICES CONTINUE RISE.
HERE'S A NEW FLASHES TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THERE'S A CLEAR-CUT WAY OF
GIVING AN ANSWER TO INCREASE
AMERICA'S SUPPLY OF OIL, GAS AND
BRING DOWN COST AND IT DOESN'T
INVOLVE -- OR LIFTING SANCTIONS
ON VENEZUELA OR IRAN OR EMPTYING
OR PETROLEUM RESERVES.
RIGHT NOW AMERICAN COMPANIES
WITH AMERICAN WORKERS, THEY CAN
PRODUCE MORE OIL AND GAS RIGHT
HERE IN AMERICA 'CAUSE WE HAVE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS A YEARS'
WORTH OF RESOURCES.
ALL THEY NEED, JOE, IS YOUR
PERMISSION AND COMMITMENT THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO UNDERCUT
THEM AND A YEAR FROM NOW AFTER
THEY INVEST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S IT.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
APPROVE FEDERAL OIL LEASES ARE
AT A FOUR DECADE LOW.
DOMESTIC DRILLING AND
EXPLORATION RESTRICTIONS ARE AT
AN ALL TIME HIGH.
AND THE U.S. OIL AND GAS
ASSOCIATION, THEY JUST TWEETED,
QUOTE, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS ONE
OPTION LEFT AND IT IS THE ONE
OPTION THEY SHOULD HAVE NEVER
TURNED AWAY FROM IN THE FIRST
PLACE, AND THAT IS THE
U.S.-BASED OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY.
NOW, SADLY, THAT OPTION WILL
REQUIRE LOGIC AND COMMON SENSE
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO EXIST
INSIDE THE CLIMATE ALARMIST CULT
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
THIS CULT, IT GIVES DEMOCRATS A
FREE PASS TO IMPORT ALL FROM
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD SO LONG AS
WE DON'T PRODUCE IT RIGHT HERE
AT HOME DOMESTICALLY AND USE
AMERICAN WORKERS AND GIVE THEM
HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SENSE
AT ALL WHATSOEVER.
BUT REMEMBER, THIS IS ITS SAME
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT BELIEVE
THAT EVERY SINGLE WEATHER EVENT,
IF IT'S A HOT DAY IN THE SUMMER,
IF IT'S A HURRICANE DURING
HURRICANE SEASON, IF IT'S SNOW
IN THE WINTER, ALL OF IT IS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN FACT, JUST TODAY, BIDEN
PROUDLY ANNOUNCED THAT HURRICANE
IAN SETTLED THE DEBATES
SURROUNDING GLOBAL WARMING ONCE
AND FOR ALL.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT, BUT HE SAID
IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE RESERVOIRS OUT WEST ARE
DOWN TO ALMOST ZERO.
WE'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
COLORADO RIVER LOOKS MORE LIKE A
STREAM.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON.
AND I THINK THE ONE THING THIS
IS FINALLY ENDED IS THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE
SHOULD DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> HOW DOES THAT EXPLAIN ALL THE
HURRICANES IN THE 1920s, 30s,
40s?
SO THINK ABOUT IT.
JOE BIDEN IS SO DEEPLY CONCERNED
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE THAT HE NOW
REFUSES TO PRODUCE OIL AND GAS
IN THE U.S., INSTEAD WILL TRY TO
IMPORT IT FROM VENEZUELA.
LET ME ASK, DOES IT IMPACT
MOTHER EARTH IF YOU IMPORT OIL
FROM VENEZUELA, IRAN, SAUDI
ARABIA, OPEC COUNTRIES OR
RUSSIA?
DOES IT HAVE THE SAME IMPACT ON
MOTHER EARTH?
THIS IS A COUNTRY, VENEZUELA,
THAT HAS ALMOST ZERO
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS,
ESPECIALLY ON MASSIVE GAS
POWERED OIL TANKERS ACROSS T